not that one
hi there its senior editor Kevin Van Ord
standing in for reviewer Miguel
concepción to tell you about battlefield
hardline the felons of battlefield
hardline are like weak willed vampires a
quick reveal of a police badge is akin
to holding up a Holy Cross in their
faces they surrender despite being well
armed with semi-automatic rifles and
well protected with bulletproof vests if
you're slow on the draw these offenders
become as lethal as any battlefield AI
opponent you've ever faced there's no
middle ground between their willingness
to capitulate and they're cold-blooded
ruthlessness and it's hilarious
hardlines story is intended to be
appreciated as a TV action drama though
it's safe middle-of-the-road appeal
makes it more suited for the USA Network
rather than Netflix original programming
this risk-averse narrative is
underscored by its protagonist Nick
Mendoza your standard-issue straight
narrow cop just because video games run
the risk of antihero burnout doesn't
excuse Nick from being the boring one in
an ensemble cast with more interesting
characters once a weapon is in your hand
hardlines world is a complicated one
where its dangers and hostility
encouraged tactful stealth while your
all-powerful badge presents tempting
opportunities to be more out in the open
staying hidden means you get to work
against some of the most oblivious
criminals you'll face in a first-person
shooter but who needs sneaking when you
can sprint towards enemies in broad
daylight and yell freeze well before
they notice you well it's laughably
unrealistic it does not negatively
impact the overall experience at least
during the initial playthrough that's
partly because arrests yield the most
points towards the campaign's character
progression system this in turn enables
a kind of tiered stealth system
arresting taking down non-violently and
killing are all different tactics with
different rewards
the campaign's key chases are largely
forgettable despite the spectacle of
ramp jumps and dodging rockets fired
from vans
speed is instead found in two of hard
lines multiplayer modes Hotwire and
Blood Money battlefield vehicles finally
get to be more than just death dealers
and efficient transports though classic
modes like conquest and team deathmatch
are available in hardline in Hotwire
vehicles function as mobile capture
points to the players who manage to get
behind the wheel when your flooring it
these Maps can feel small but vehicles
have been synonymous with battlefield
since its inception
so placing the series in the context of
modern day heists makes a lot of sense
especially given the ubiquity of the
getaway van it's essential in Blood
Money a mode where both the cops and
robbers are looting and evidence vaults
of cash at the center of the map the
importance of a getaway vehicle near the
vault can't be understated since a
packed van of proper villains with bags
of loot can turn the tide in the brief
time span of a single cash delivery this
emphasis on teamwork highlights one of
the core values of battlefield a series
that popularized rewarding players for
contributions beyond mere kill counts
and other individual achievements Wheel
men who stay close to players making
cash deposits or awarded proximity
bonuses it's rare to get this much
gratification from being a mere shuttle
driver going back and forth between two
points the influence of eSports is felt
in hard lines 2 5 vs. 5 modes crosshair
and rescue rescue is a well-designed
retrieval game type in which the law
enforcement side has to save one hostage
at the other end of the map visceral
games wisely provided two hostages to
choose from per round a design choice
that helps spread out the hostage takers
thereby balancing sides in an otherwise
lopsided mode equally unpredictable as
crosshair where the police are tasked
with escorting an informant to a
rendezvous point even though the cops do
not have to stick together and the VIP
is well armed crosshair often turns into
an engaging guessing game for those
hunting the snitch
Nicke mendosa right oh hey look at it
[ __ ] just got real the simplicity of the
campaign stealth gameplay and the
enemy's readiness to submit at the sound
of freeze is pretty comical even if that
wasn't the intention still these
features don't detract too much from the
overall enjoyment of the single-player
which is the first battlefield campaign
since Bad Company twos to argue for its
own existence online play on the other
hand requires few caveats it wasn't that
long ago that the ability to eject from
a fighter plane and seamlessly continue
the battle on foot was one of the more
awe-inspiring things you could do in a
first-person shooter that's why many
gravitated to the battlefield series in
the first place and hardline isn't short
of similar transitional vehicular
moments this is an Evo Jima or an
Arabian oil field but it's still pure
battlefield